how's it going everybody since we
recently received the new venom trailer
just a little bit over a week ago that
showed us a lot of new symbiote action
it's starting to win people over quick
reminder about the Avengers infinity war
blu-ray giveaway that I'm doing if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win a copy all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero a lot of people at first were
really worried about them doing a solo
venom movie the first teaser trailer
came out and it didn't even show venom
so that made a lot of people angry and
it made us even more worried about the
movie but then the second trailer came
out and we actually got a glimpse at
venom we got this little clip right here
so obviously people freaked out because
it's an amazing clip and we finally saw
venom and for the most part everybody
was happy about it but we were still
wondering are we going to get a venom
that is true to the comics and honestly
people were still worried about what the
symbiotes were gonna look like but about
a week and a half ago we got the latest
venom trailer and people freaked because
it was super awesome and we got a lot of
looks at the new symbiotes so everybody
for the most part is pretty happy with
the way that the movie looks so far
which I'm really happy about cuz I hope
the movie does really well I hope they
spin this off into even more movies I
know we all want to movie with carnage
in it and I know we all want to see
venom fight spider-man so this is
ultimately really good news that it's
being received well even the original
creators of venom from the comics are
actually pretty pleased with him Todd
McFarlane who is one of the original
creators of venom actually took to
social media recently to talk about just
how cool venom looks and about a few
changes he could make if he had that
power it's a really cool video I enjoyed
watching it and I thought you all would
too so here you go Wolf Wolf
everybody todd mcfarlane we're gonna do
everybody bench in the cool trailer to
the venom movie coming up it's gonna be
cool each time they show a new video
just gets better and better and better
and better right and then did some cool
imagery so here's a shot people keep
asking me Todd what do you think of it I
think it looks pretty cool and most of
the spots there so but I would just do
some little tiny tweaks if my name
wasn't Todd it was God but it only
rhymes with God so it's Todd's and we'll
show you what would happen if they made
me God
right now the let's look at it right
here the eyes come down like this I
think they come too close to each other
and they come down this way so it looks
a little bit like he's looking towards
the center of his nose as you guys
remember I did the eyes love that more
like this so that you got way more black
so if we come in here if we add some
black up in here to give just a little
bit more black here and then we'll do a
stamp there we go a little bit smaller
get some lines in there
alright let's just pick a color here
let's go with this color
dun dun dun eyes get a little bit bluer
come up in here and then see right here
he's got a little bit of too much of a
smile I would I would carve the teeth
back just a little bit more so if you
just hide just like our own teeth
they sort of go back just a little bit
more right here right here
and they start to curve so that
eventually you wouldn't really see some
of these ones back up in here they go
back just a little bit right and then
I'd make I'd make so that all the teeth
aren't really sort of the same sort of
same size I'd shorten some of them so
I'd make them so that somewhere the ones
in the front maybe a little bit shorter
and then you get the big fangs in the
back there so I'd give it a little bit
of variety to it just a bit same thing
over here alright I tighten so there's a
mouth up in here tighten it up in here
just a bit get some black in here get
some blue in here
and that's it not much right okay I
think it looks really cool which I think
could not I like the big shoulders on
them he's looking really awesome looking
with the big shoulders because again I
always thought of him sort of more like
a gorilla
so there's nice and big but watch watch
when I click off this right here well
let's see let's go here do a couple of
things here one two three now watch when
I click it off right it's a little bit
of a tweak little smiley here just looks
a little more Savage let me put a little
more black here big smart now what I
could do is I could be here and then
when he smiles
wow he opens his mouth bigger right so
you get more animation in it right when
you get more as eyes bigger eye movement
but anyway touch it by the way I think
it looks pretty cool Tom Hardy doing a
good job the Train looks good I'm hoping
for big things on it see you then
[Music]
[Music]